went back down stairs and got to the
booking section and I had a look around
and you couldn't see Sarah anyway
when they marched me into the police
office and some you down thought my life
had ended
I guess I'll see ya merci Mon bourgie no
Simon Berg when the tickets were booked
his but as a party of two
so my name with his name couldn't see
sales and every thought well I'll head
towards the check-in there's no salt
chicken in a gentleman tap on the
shoulder and started speaking to me in
Spanish Familia there was other
oh right what come with me come why yes
I started come with me come with me and
also why why then it will take me
I've never ever been that stopped by the
police before so sudden is what's happen
with sale thank you the air the door
open inside came it then then I was like
what
oh what's happening here Sara didn't
really look at me didn't really say
anything try and say anything I'm I'm I
understand to race thinking of all the
different possibilities but still
thinking now this is cop here mistake
Thank You Anita Mia when they start
taking my clothes out of the suitcase
one of the women was holding up will not
my clothing and trying it on and saying
oh this is nice and I was saying it's
not your stuff that it's not yours
I mean when I be looking when I saw
there was a long long break in a luggage
I just can't understand him so what if
we bought that for it just doesn't make
any sense to me
it's just ridiculous when they search my
hand luggage they from my passport
all right who's bar is this I took my
passport so that if anything happened I
had to disguise could put my wig on I've
got my other passport and if let's even
go to the embassy or I can do something
I don't quite plant what that's why I've
lined the passport my lips the case I
pulled out three black packets borrow
doing this they were filming it all I
don't know what to do so I just sat
there so just staring at them thinking I
don't believe this
I don't believe this
he's policy thief for drugs
oh it's bad not mine please understand
that this is nothing to do with me it
please you've got understanding isn't
anything to do with me eh then come the
packets
and emptied the contents into the bag
and it was flying everywhere
piles and piles of it
when they put on the scales at wait nine
point eight nine kilos
I'm understanding in Simon up making a
stand behind the table and then pull all
the cocaine in front of us like it's
like it's some slide show what about
that drive I don't take drugs you can
test me why are you here
Simon holiday yeah you know something
about the dress
you